[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña a robert garcía meteorólogo del
servicio meteorológico nacional de eeuu
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros y
quiero comenzar preguntándole si es
idiota la tormenta más fuerte que ha
golpeado a centroamérica
hoy está corriendo para ese título
estamos viendo lo que queda de yota está
el centro estar cerca del salvador
y estamos viendo que muchas de estas
áreas de nicaragua y honduras no
solamente sufrieron de yota pero también
está la semana pasada y estamos viendo
que esta tormenta estuvo bastante un
tiempo fue una huracán de categoría 4
llegando a 5 y es una cosa que acaba con
cualquier el edificio o algunas otras
cosas que están en el cerca de la costa
pero ahora estamos viendo que las
inundaciones más adentro son el problema
más grande de estas áreas los ríos están
inundados
hay inundaciones repentinas y también
deslizamientos de la tierra usted nos
estaba diciendo que esto sucede después
del paso de eta son dos fenómenos
meteorológicos en menos de dos semanas
esto es normal para las temporadas de
tormentas y huracanes
no es imposible verlo y ese es el
problema de esta área está los aspectos
bastante también con inundaciones y esta
fue una tormenta de categoría 4 también
es casi el mismo lugar con una tormenta
de casi la misma intensidad y por eso
están estamos viendo la destrucción y
los problemas que vienen asociados con
estas tormentas en tan corto de un
tiempo
bueno y adicionalmente de su revolver de
san andrés y providencia las islas
colombianas nunca habían sufrido un
desastre como el que estamos viendo en
estos días por un huracán qué efecto
produce que ahora lleguen estas
tormentas a esta región y pues es que
para los colombianos esto es una
tragedia inédita
por una cosa siempre aquí en los eeuu
siempre estamos hablando de estas
tormentas que son no son el centro pero
son fenómenos grandes y
desafortunadamente colombia está viendo
inundaciones porque esta tormenta está
trayendo humedad de la ecuador y el
pacífico sobre el área no solamente de
centroamérica pero también colombia aquí
vemos que en la costa de colombia cerca
está todavía queda humedad y energía de
la tormenta tenemos que mirar que hay
otra área que es posible que se
desarrolle en los próximos días y con
eso puede agravar la situación en
colombia y en centroamérica con más
lluvias eso es una cosa en los próximos
45 días que vamos a tener que mirar
también ve posible que desarrolle otra
vez en algo tropical que pueda hacer más
daño con los vientos también bueno y la
pregunta obligada a robert es si existe
una relación entre el calentamiento
global y la llegada de estos fenómenos
cada vez más frecuentes en el caribe
de lo que nos enseña lo último la última
información de los estudios es que el
calentamiento global es posible que
influencie la cantidad de actividad pero
también la intensidad de la actividad de
lo que estamos viendo ahora es una de
las cosas que los estudios enseñan que
más lluvias tormentas más intensas en
más tiempo también en la temporada de
ahora la temporada va a terminar aquí a
terminar de noviembre pero el 2005 que
fue el último año que estuvimos las
letras griegas nos enseñó que diciembre
y ese año una tormenta se quedó de
diciembre hasta enero no no estoy
diciendo que va a pasar este año pero
también tenemos que estar vigilando lo
que está pasando porque todavía hay
bastante energía en el bacín atlántico y
el caribe bueno y ya para el cierre de
robert enke modelos climáticos sólo
pueden predecir ustedes a partir de los
fenómenos que estamos viendo este año
una cosa que el patrón estamos mirando
para el invierno en la en la esférica
norte norte que está aumentando una la
niña que el pacífico se está enfriando
un poco y como eso normalmente para la
parte de las américas especialmente en
américa y entrando a las partes norte de
centroamérica es un posiblemente un
invierno más seco y más caliente y eso
vamos a tener que mirar cómo sigue el
invierno pero es posible que algunas
áreas del caribe no vean tantas lluvias
en el invierno normalmente el tiempo
seco pero es posible que sea un poquito
más seco con más taquilla
robert muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros a nuestros televidentes también
gracias por su compañía y seguimos en
france 24
[Música]